hey everybody welcome back to planet
coaster
it's been a while since i last made a
video but i thought that due to recent
events that i could make a
new video so here we are although
actually this video is a few months old
i have to be honest i recorded this
somewhere at the start of the lockdown
and due to all kinds of circumstances i
just haven't released it
until now which is the day that i'm
putting out this video but as i am
saying this
i'm not even i'm not even sure if i
believe myself that it's going to come
out soon because
this video has gone through so many ups
and downs just to give you a quick
update because it's also a sort of a
live update
i recorded this somewhere in the middle
of lockdown when i was just spending all
of my time inside on discord trying to
avoid
cabin fever and i just wanted to have a
small side project in planet coaster so
this will just be a
a quick one and done kind of thing which
honestly i'm
kind of starting to enjoy and i just had
the time lapse laying on my computer for
a while until i finally decided to
record commentary for it which i lost
somewhere along the way
um later i tried to get back into it
record some cinematics
i really liked those cinematics but i
deleted them because i accidentally
recorded them into a planet zoo folder
and recently when i was cleaning up my
hard drive
i found these recordings in the planet 2
folder i figured
i've released all of my planets to raw
files so it should be fine
deleted them and now just realized that
i
threw away part of this project kind of
unfortunate um
and then i lost most of my motivation
for this as well
but today my three terabyte hard drive
that i record videos on
is completely full and i need to get
some stuff out there
and since this has been sitting for so
long i want to get this out of the way
quick um also honestly i have been
recording things the past couple weeks i
know
the past months honestly i've been kind
of inactive on youtube
partly that is because i've just been
really busy with school writing my
thesis and everything and moving back to
the netherlands where i'm once again
living
but also honestly i just haven't turned
most of my footage actually into videos
so i just
need to start working away at that and
actually editing stuff
so that's just a quick live update now
about this video itself actually
the inspiration for this actually very
much came from the lockdown as well
because
as i would do i was on discord with some
friends discussing
gravity group wooden coasters and
looking at povs and things like this
when i realized that i really wanted to
try my hand at one of these as well
and not just a wooden coaster in general
but a very particular type
of gravity group wounded coasters which
isn't really officially a type but it's
definitely
some kind of archetype that you see
popping up recently i'm talking about
wooden roller coasters that are
somewhere between 10 and 20 meters in
height
have very short trains of about six or
five cars
and tend to focus on air time and stay
very close to the ground in their
layouts
and feature lots of bunny hops and quick
changes in direction
and i would say this is very much a
gravity group specialty
i think there's some interesting
examples in the us of these kinds of
coasters like kentucky flyer
in kentucky kingdom and of course
oscar's wacky taxi which is a coaster
that has
kind of become a meme with coaster
enthusiasts for its name
but honestly i've also seen it get rave
reviews for being a really fun coaster
on a tiny footprint
and i think there are some really good
examples of it closer to my home as well
there's timber in wali bihon alp which
is a coaster that i haven't been on yet
but i would love to
ride it one day it's it's similarly a
very small wooden coaster although it's
slightly bigger than most of these
coasters at about 17 meters in height
um and there's one example in europe as
well that i have actually been on which
is twister in groninland in stockholm
which i absolutely love to bits it's a
little bit different
from many of the other gravity group
mini woodies in a sense that it's much
more twisty because it's trying to
make its way through the already very
crammed layout of the gronalund
theme park which is just one of the most
compact if not
the most compact theme park i've ever
seen
what's especially nuts is that right now
they are building
a b m inverted coaster going through the
middle of the park
you can look that part up on um on
google maps
because it's close to the city center of
stockholm it's not too hard to find it's
just across the water from there
um and it's a really beautiful park but
just looking at it on google
maps i'm absolutely flabbergasted how
they are going to fit a b
m invert in there i've seen the plans
and
i guess it makes sense but it's just
ridiculous how compact that park is i
know i'm getting very off topic but i
just want to gush about this park for a
second it's so cool
um like for instance right next to
twister the woody they have this
uh the jet line which is a swatch
coaster
and they also have a bobsled kind of uh
wild
mouse coaster there um which just uses
the support structure for the swatch cup
looping coaster and wiggles its way
through the layout of that coaster
if you've ever built scenarios with very
limited land
in roller coaster tycoon and you had to
end up you know snaking your coasters
layouts through each other that's
exactly how grownund feels
i i've never seen a theme park which is
so
essentially rollercoaster tycoon in in
all of its design it's beautiful
it's amazing it's also really charming
highly recommend visiting it if you're
ever in stockholm but yeah
you have twister there which is also a
gravity group wooden coaster and very
similar to this
so with this layout i just tried to make
a
very much in the same spirit a layout
with a height
of somewhat about 14 meters actually
only i believe
a quick pre-drop followed by a turn
around with which many of these wooden
coasters do
uh into a double up there just popping a
little bit of air time
on each of the hills coming back down
and doing some twisty section
out and back and returning with a few
more small bunny hops
and some twists and turns until you're
back in the station
it's not like there's a lot of variety
in the layout as you can see
but really there's only so much you can
do with such a small roller coaster i
think the focus
of these and what makes them so
interesting to me personally
is that they really try to make the best
out of their very limited stats
and i think it's a great case for why
roller coasters don't necessarily have
to be large to be good
and maybe this is just kind of a
personal preference for me but i love
mini roller coasters or rollercoasters
that you know do something that big
roller coasters are well known for
but on a much smaller scale because
essentially you can still get the same
elements and the same enjoyment and even
the same
forces out of a smaller coaster as you
can with a bigger coaster it just won't
be as impressive
and the forces won't be as sustained but
it's very much possible
and many of these wooden coasters can
yank you out of your chair
just as much as a giant wooden coaster
does and
sometimes even do much better than big
and bigger wooden coasters so
i really love that one of my favorite
coasters is also the intamin mega light
like biraten at uh juris summerland in
denmark
or um in tobu zoo japan kawasemi
which are really amazing coasters and i
honestly
prefer them over most bigger intamin
mega coasters that i've been on
just because they just make everything
out of their tiny layouts they're very
small they're kind of cute
but they just maximize the amount of air
time that you can get out of it and
just that whole philosophy and i think
these types of wooden coasters have the
same kind of philosophy
i don't know i just like it a lot it
also leads to roller coasters that have
no
sense of downtime if you will i
definitely know some bigger roller
coasters that at least have some
sections where you feel like
you know you're out of the action for a
bit or you're just moving in between
elements for me personally and i guess
this is kind of a hot take but for me
personally
expedition geforce kind of feels like
this i know most
roller coaster enthusiasts definitely
theme park review
still build expedition geforce as the
best roller coaster in the world or at
least one of the best in the world
but to me honestly those moments of
downtime where it just has a small
straight section or something where you
don't quite have the same forces
kind of detract from the experience and
i find that some of these smaller
courses just keep up the insanity from
beginning to end which i just love when
rollercoasters do that so yeah
i try to make that work a bit with this
coaster as well
now i'm also going on about the roller
coaster itself because
really i was mostly inspired for the
layout of this coaster everything else
i'm doing in this video is just
the necessary theming and scenery that i
need to do to make it
make it past as a realistic ride but
honestly
the focus here was really on the coaster
so i'm keeping everything quite
minimalistic
the station for instance is just a
simple
wooden shed quite generic um kind of
what i
imagine a wally be vaguely
american themed ride would be it's not
you know really quite anything it
doesn't specifically have an in-depth
story
or theming but just the vague aesthetics
of a sort of northern north american
mining town or logging town or something
like that
now just for realism's sake i am adding
a small
transfer table as well which honestly i
was a little bit stressed about for
most of me building this ride because i
really couldn't figure out how to make
this thing work eventually i'm not sure
if my
final solution was featured on the video
or not because
i start out with just building it from
that curve but i quickly realized that
it was impossible to bring the car
back from there so in the end i just had
to resort to building a small switch
track here
at the end of the station actually where
the cars could move backwards
into the transfer table because really
in this super
limited space that i moved myself into
here
it seems like the only realistic option
i also think i actually made the trains
one car
shorter because i didn't have space for
a larger transfer table so i just had to
you know base the the length of the
train on that as well
but in the end i think it works out and
it at least makes the coaster feel like
it could be real
another thing that i wanted to do for
this coaster is
obviously some custom supporting but
because this is a side project
and i don't want to get too much into it
and i don't want to do another
usury gardens where i just build a giant
custom supported wooden coaster
i'm just keeping it very minimal this
time around and trying to focus on just
the
bare basics i did
look a little bit into what gravity
group coaster supports tend to look like
because every wooden coaster i've tried
to support in planet coasters so far
was a great coasters international
coaster which
uses different support structures
i don't know exactly what their
different methods
are but it's pretty clear from looking
at their coasters that they have
different designs for the track and
supports
so for this one i mostly looked at
timber uh to try and get an idea of what
to do with the supports
and to try and also see how i can
retrofit the already existing supports
in the game
uh to my benefit instead of just
building completely new supports from
scratch because
i mean i think also these outside
supports
do give the biggest bang for the buck it
doesn't take that much effort
to add some supports onto the already
existing in-game supports
um but it just makes it look a little
bit more realistic not to mention that
the game
does tend to make under-supported wooden
coasters
you know not even for a specific company
um
style i think it's important to add
these extra wooden beams because it just
looks very flimsy if you don't
and the in-game support generation can
very
often create under-supported wooden
coasters so
i i don't want to feel like the coaster
is is
barely hanging on by a thread so i'm at
least adding some custom supports to
also make it feel a little bit more
sturdy and especially i think these
lateral supports on the outside of
curves
are quite iconic for these kinds of
smaller wooden coasters even
so i think for the the general aesthetic
of the coaster it's also quite important
to add
the biggest addition to the supports i
would say is actually
on the outside here of this curve where
i'm just hooking up to the height
of the already existing supports and
adding some lateral beams to that as
well
which honestly i think there are many
ways that you can just save time for
this like
for instance building one basic supports
that you can move around
because the whole structure is the same
height and then just connecting the
beams in between that there's
often no reason to build every single
beam individually
of course you could do that if you want
to have a very specific
um like detailed support structure as
you would see in real life but i think
this is a good
compromise where it doesn't take too
much time it might not be
exactly how it would look in real life
but it's close enough
and reasonable enough that you don't
spend too much time working on it
i've seen many people um well i say many
people but i've seen some people
really only rarely build completely
you know individually placed hand-built
wooden supports for coasters in planet
coaster
and while i have to say it looks amazing
and
i really respect the work in it it's
it's honestly something that i don't
really have the time and patience to do
and i think you can very well with with
copy paste techniques and trying to add
to what the supports in the game already
offer you can you can do
things that look almost as good in
much less time so especially because
wooden coasters are one of the most time
consuming things to build with all of
the support work included
it's it's something that i feel is is a
good way to also
prevent yourself from being deterred
from ever
trying a wooden coaster because it can
just seem like such a
daunting task if you want to do it and
you really want to do it realistically
i mean it is interesting though uh just
to get into some really
random rollercoaster trivia that in real
life
i think wooden coasters are also
insanely
complicated and take a lot of
maintenance and work
compared to steel coasters for instance
they are cheaper to buy but mostly
because the materials are cheaper
but after that they have to be
constantly maintained and they
constantly have to have their places
their tracks repaired or uh replaced
so honestly these things are very
complicated beasts and
every single plank and beam has to be in
the right place
and has to be checked regularly so
these things honestly are super
complicated
and i know i'm a rollercoaster
enthusiast
in a sense and i'll write rollercoasters
because i love the thrill of it but i
also
really respect the engineering of it and
especially with wooden coasters
the sheer amount of work that goes into
well
making it all work is really absurd and
just playing a video game and making
roller coasters in that
is really the easiest part that you can
imagine and the real life situation is
just so much more
insanely complex but yeah
i'm uh i'm gonna go back to the world of
planet coaster for a bit
i decided to add some beams here as well
which i'll be honest
maybe a little bit unnecessary but at
some points i just figured
i really like the look of these beams at
it on the outside of curves
so i ended up just going with it another
thing to keep in mind of course when
you're supporting a wooden coaster is
that you really have to be sure that
your layout is entirely
in place and it's as smooth as you want
to for this coaster i
kind of lost my patience at some point
smoothing it and i figured might as well
just start adding some supports
but at this point there's no going back
as soon as you smooth anything a little
bit
it'll be ever so slightly out of touch
with the supports around it
and everything won't work anymore so
yeah you really have to be careful with
that
it's it's pretty much all set in stone
once you start building the supports
so here's the the transfer table which
i'm keeping very simple
not really adding too much in the way of
mechanisms too
it's slightly slanted because the the
track over here is actually slightly
slanted as well because it is going down
into the station after all
i think wooden coasters are one of the
coaster types where the fact
that straits coaster track does not
exist becomes
very clear obviously games like roller
coaster tycoon and the like have made
the idea that you have
straight sections on roller coasters
kind of generally accept an idea
but in reality coasters will almost
always be on a slight incline
and especially with older coasters and
wooden coasters they will always be on
an incline
even in the station and i think with
some of these gravity group wooden
coasters you can tell it very clearly
that just the whole station is a slant
and the entire brake run
leading down into the station is slanted
as well
and um with many wooden coasters you can
even tell that the brake runs
are are kind of diagonal i think um
gravity group winning coasters are
particularly well known for this
uh many of their their break sections
are actually
banked so that the um well i don't know
the exact
technical terms but the way that the the
brakes work the the fin
on the coaster car that has to catch
into the brakes
uh and and has to be uh slowing the
train down by friction
that has to um i mean i say friction but
usually magnetic brakes but yeah it has
to be
caught right by the brakes so because of
that reason often the brakes are
slightly banked just so that the
magnetic brakes will work
i'm not sure if the same is true for
friction brakes so i shouldn't say
anything
about it but pointing cases on a wooden
coaster you're almost always at least
going down or
up in some way and um very often not
even
entirely straight even if you think you
are so all of that just to say that
my final break run and transfer tables
also on a very slight tilt
now something that i wanted to try with
this coaster because it is quite generic
and i at least wanted to add some
scenery to it not to mention
i wanted to make this coaster blueprint
friendly as well so
um i figured this would be a good way to
do that one thing i wanted to do is add
some very generic
planters around it to kind of give it
some landscaping without having to rely
on terraforming which of course doesn't
translate with a blueprint
and my idea for that was just to build
some large planters that
kind of follow the smooth flowing
layouts of the the coaster itself
which was honestly slightly annoying to
place
um but for those who are watching this
and have never
heard or seen my trick for this usually
what i do
is i get one of those half walls where
the top is a is a half wall section and
the bottom is a full wall
i think they're meant for large windows
but honestly i'm not entirely sure what
those pieces are for
but if you sink it into the ground so
that only the half wall section is
above the ground what you get is a piece
that when you rotate it
it'll always be completely flush with
itself
like it'll rotate in a way that you
don't have to
remove replace it in any way or move it
around in a 3d space to try and
connect the next wall to the last one
all you have to do is rotate it in the
direction that you want to go
shift it out of the wall that you're
currently in and it'll automatically be
flush
with the wall that you built before it
and it just makes it way easier to build
these kind of round
shapes you never have to try and fiddle
with the pieces to make them connect
right and it just kind of makes them fun
almost
of course it's still kind of a grueling
task because you have to place many
different small wall pieces to create
these curves
and you have to try and get the curves
to to be as smooth as possible and of
course
fill it in with some mulch as well like
i'm doing here
but at the end of the day it's it's a
much easier way to do these kinds of
things
and it's surprisingly fun i think to
build these curved
wall sections especially because i feel
it looks so
out of the game because the game doesn't
really offer
any any pieces like this that are so
round out of the box
and um yeah it just makes everything uh
look a bit more smooth and
they're always great to to make
especially modern themed builds
uh come together landscaping wise
now i'm not entirely sure why i decided
to build
this whole section on a concrete pad but
i figured it would be good to have a
small
backstage section where i'm storing all
kinds of roller coaster goodies
and where um the stuff will be working
so that's really all that's that's out
here a little bit of machinery for the
transfer table some
leftover crates and pellets and storage
stuff
nothing too special also a door so that
you can actually get
into the lower section of the transfer
table there
which maybe shouldn't even have had a
floor to begin with
but i mean i'm happy keeping it this way
i just wanted to add some very small
details that also
breed the sign of life into the game and
make it look like this thing is actually
functional
and finally it was time to also
put some foliage into these planters i
didn't want to go
too crazy on the collars in here because
honestly i'm really bad
when it comes to colors and flowers and
stuff you might have noticed i don't do
a lot of flowers on my videos and
i've never really done that because i'm
not the greatest at making
good flower arrangements so i'm just
keeping everything very simple here
focusing
mostly on green stuff and a few flowers
and some colored accents
not to mention that this does seem like
a coaster that would be good for a small
lower budget
park which realistically is where these
kinds of coasters are built in real life
and that part could honestly not really
afford giant flower beds anyway so
i think it works like this and finally
i'm really just adding a bunch of
context around the right here to make it
feel like it's
actually in a map and not just in the
middle of nowhere of an empty sandbox
so most of the rest of this video will
just be spent
adding some forestry around this whole
area
there's just one more planter that you
know when i looked
and and zoomed out of the map to try and
see how everything looked
i felt like something was missing and it
just felt like
there had to be something built here on
this side to
to counterbalance all of the other
planter shapes
and i figured i might as well add this
final section here
now i want to just fast forward for a
second and move to when i finish that
planter to discuss a little bit of
pathworks
um because kind of like the supports of
the wooden coaster i want to keep the
paths
as in game and simple as possible while
at least adding some touches to it to
make sure it doesn't look too generic
so i'm leaving the in-game curbs intact
i know
some people like to just completely
replace the curbs but
honestly to me that also sounds like a
lot of work for only a minor change
and i think especially for a small build
like this it works to just try and see
if you can retro fit the curves in any
way
so for the side there i added some small
rope fences
and for these parts i'm once again doing
the half wall trick
except just with a different texture
this time around to try and fill in the
connections between
the planters also something i think
that's worth pointing out is that the
planters do have lights
at least on the sections where we don't
have these lanterns next to it
uh just those small wall lights that
shine on the path
which honestly are some of my favorite
types of lights to add to any part it's
so simple you just
sync the lights into the walls on the
sides and it just creates a really
beautiful effect
at night and you don't have to worry
about the lighting otherwise it's very
minimalistic
it's something you don't have to think
about too much but it works out really
beautifully especially with these kinds
of
minimalistic modern architecture builds
i know there isn't a lot of architecture
in this but i
imagine that these kinds of round
concrete planters could work very well
with
contemporary architecture if you're ever
building you know that kind of theme
park
but yeah the rest of this video is
really all just
the boring building tree lines which
i've done many times before
it's funny how to me at this point it
kind of feels like
i'm going back to the days of planet
coaster college
because this is what i would always use
to do of uh with the layouts of the
coasters once i was finished
just build a giant tree line around the
map that
isn't necessarily realistic because this
is of course not how a real forest would
look
but it's the kind of thing that i think
from a distance looks
realistic quite quickly without too much
effort
by stacking all of these trees in
multiple layers
but within a very tight space you can
very quickly make the outside world
invisible
while making it seem like there's
actually a very dense and complex forest
when in reality it's released a wall of
trees that quickly blocks the outside
view
so nothing too realistic there honestly
but yeah i'm gonna keep a few secrets of
this build for the final cinematics as
well so
i'm gonna skip forward and let you guys
just
enjoy some cinematic shots and the pov
of this coaster
hope you guys enjoyed this random little
planet coaster video
i'll be working on perhaps some planet
coaster stuff in the future as well i
definitely don't want to leave this game
behind i know many people are
um thinking about you know whether i'm
really coming back to this game because
honestly the problem is that there are
many games on my mind but planet coaster
will always be the game that
made my channel what it is today i
suppose and
ultimately it's also where my heart lies
with theme parks and everything
so who knows i have no idea when
or what my next planet coaster venture
is going to be
but ultimately there will probably be
some times when i feel like just making
a small side project roller coaster
anyway i'll leave you guys thanks for
watching
and we'll see each other in the next
video i guess
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you